muito bom tá aqui ó que coisa bacana ter
passado essa experiência com vocês o dia
inteiro muito muito feliz
tem encontrado tantos belos exemplos de
pessoas que não só os construíram suas
vidas como também desconstruir a si
próprios através de uma identificação de
que existem alguns mitos algumas
ladainhas e alguns mini miss que a nossa
cultura nos coloca diariamente e isso é
um verdadeiro complexo caldeirão da
nossa vida de fazer com que nós vamos
perceber que parte ou um grande conjunto
de tudo que nós vivemos o que nos é
repassados
nós precisamos desconstruir os nós
precisamos jogar para fora e às vezes
até achar que são mentiras inteira me
difícil mudar comportamento é difícil
mudar pequenas palavras eu
especificamente eu sou eu fui nascido e
criado em recife é não completei meu
curso de graduação porque achei que eu
queria empreender
comecei empreendedor 17 anos e aos 20
anos abandonou o curso de computação
bênção mais de 20 anos de carreira nesse
processo pouco menos de 20 anos na
verdade de carreira nesse processo se
contar os 18 anos são 21 38 anos
hoje eu tenho nesse momento eu tenho
oito empresas espalhadas no brasil há
quase todas elas voltadas ou que se
utilizam a de muita gente de muita
tecnologia mas eu tenho 17 sócios mais
de 500 funcionários espalhados em vários
escritórios e isso é um desafio contínuo
são jovens na sua grande maioria das
vezes são pessoas também maduras e
executivos seniores também em algumas
dessas empresas é muito bacana perceber
como eles nem percebem
isso é uma pergunta constante não
imagina a quantidade de pessoas que
entram em sites vida e tantos todas as
pessoas que querem encontrar seus
objetivos e seus sua maneira de ser
em descobrir se elas estão felizes e
obviamente elas entram aí elas voltam e
é muito bacana quando você tem uma
pessoa que já confiam em você de volta a
confiar em você diz cara eu gosto desse
trabalho
vamos voltar a trabalhar juntos vamos
ser bacana enquanto nós fomos felizes
nós vamos trabalhar já que a gente já
conseguiu descobrir importantes
depoimentos absolutamente
extraordinários que o trabalho é um
contexto na vida das pessoas
o que importa é a busca da felicidade
que você tem
eu sou fazedor eu não sou um pensador a
assim como sou muito pouco observador
eu sou parte da categoria das pessoas
que fazem e executam
apesar de que eu faço poucas perguntas
eu estou continuamente observando mas eu
observo menos do que eu faço eu faço
muito mais do que observa em especial o
primeiro uma primeira observação que eu
queria
depois dessa minha experiência de todas
as pessoas trabalhando nessa minha parte
dessa história é entender esses dois
grandes conceitos que foram trilhados
aqui aliás brilhantemente telhado agora
pelo felipe
há sem dúvida nenhuma a desculpa seu
nome pela juliana aí pela andré também
né empregos e oportunidades
tem muito emprego e sem sombra de dúvida
mas tem muito mais oportunidades para o
emprego na verdade já está enterrado num
caixão a sete palmos do chão cabul sem
emprego
se você procurar um emprego é algo que
foi colocado numa ladainha na sua vida
que você tem que estudar você tem que
informar que você tem que ir atrás
depois você tem que passar por um
programa de trainee ou depois tem que
buscar oportunidade ea partir daí você
vai ter que ganhar o dinheiro para poder
criar a família comprou casa
lindo é para isso que parece que serve o
emprego
eu acho que o brasil passa por um
período pelos próximos e com certeza nos
próximos cinco anos
talvez brilhantemente
por nós próprios de ter colocado tanto
de gente bacana nesse processo de ter
ido atrás e ter construído essas
oportunidades que estão nos apresentando
nós temos tantos ilhas de excelência de
grandes oportunidades como tema os
desafios absolutamente incríveis desde
índices do pisa em desigualdade social
mesmo tempo em brasília todo canto do
mundo viajando sim de vida não quer mais
oportunidades do que é pra você poder
fazer alguma coisa bacana é maravilhoso
não tem porque reclamar está gostando
emprego muda se não tá gostando de
nenhum emprego empreende se não está
conseguido empreender em busca de
autoconhecimento se não consegue nem se
autoconhecer aí meu filho tá difícil
aí é melhor você estudar o mercado
começar a encontrar pessoas que vão te
ajudar a descobrir primeiro quem é você
o fato de você aprender alguma coisa aí
atrás de uma oportunidade
primeiro você tem que se autoconhecer
porque é doloroso e é bem difícil você
passar por ela
claro que para você buscar oportunidade
você tem que tentar muito e cada
tentativa dessa é um risco porque pode
dar errado e vai ser mais uma vez
doloroso como felipe colocou doloroso
não do ponto de vista financiamento fala
é mais doloroso para as pessoas que
estão à sua volta que colocaram o
primeiro mito uma expectativa em relação
a você eu não sei se vocês sabem
a expectativa é a mãe da frustração
desafio número 1 temos que acabar com
isso as pessoas têm que acreditar porque
estou tentando isso é bacana
então vamos arriscar e pra arriscar é
claro que é uma condição inexorável
errar e é a agora desconstruído é bom é
bom ela é bom falei falei eu já tive
duas falências derrota total falência
pessoal e dinheiro pra todo mundo mas
foi bom
aprendi com isso graças a deus eu tinha
minha esposa meus irmãos que disseram o
técnico à frente faz parte da sua
oportunidade de crescimento e de você
conseguir ganhar muito pra algumas vezes
você acertar isso é bacana é ramon errar
muito é ruim
aprender com os próprios erros
isso é mais uma ladainha que a gente
sempre ouve se muito à la a prenda ou se
olham pra tá na hora que você fez o seu
rastro
todo mundo sempre nos diz já aprendeu
com seus próprios erros
se a coisa mais falsa que eu acho que o
universo já colocou à nossa vista pelo
amor de deus
obs essa frase somente os burros
aprendem com os próprios erros
é óbvio que eu quero aprender com vocês
eu quero aprender com os erros de vocês
é muito mais simples
nessa era do conhecimento com a nossa
agora nossa reputação nossa economia da
reputação que recebeu ontem um vídeo
brilhante
eu não vou aprender com as outras
pessoas e não vou circular os meus
próprios erros com os erros dos outros e
aprender com eles têm que ser muito
besta para não fazer isso é verdade tem
que errar muito e errar repetidas vezes
que você não saber ouvir e para saber
ouvir a primeira e melhor característica
até de um procedimento científico é você
saber é licitar e licitar nada mais é
uma conversa de você saber perguntar a
qualquer pergunta se não adianta chegar
para alice viana que está aqui na minha
frente e perguntar sobre a ver com a sua
vida de luciana e ela vai dizer está
ótimo claro que eu só posso dizer isso é
preciso fazer perguntas válidas
perguntas que eu consiga aprender para
iniciar uma troca um conjunto de
conversas e interações com qualquer um
desses grandes
líderes dessas grandes pessoas que
compartilharam e colaboraram conosco
colaborar nessa palavra fantástica eu
gosto demais da versão dela com ação com
laboração em icó querem muita gente em
dupla tem de labor de trabalho tem cola
de unir e tem de ação de praticar olha
só tudo isso uma única palavra isso é
muito bacana saber colaborar
uma coisa importante e vital para o seu
próprio aprendizado e para que você
aprenda pelo menos com os bons e huss
procure líderes mas não só aqueles
líderes das biografias os líderes que
você lê nos livros de administração
não adianta procurar os líderes que
estavam aqui nesta minha posição
os líderes que você pode ter conversas
imagine você passar o dia inteiro com
chutes sua maravilhosa poluída conversar
e conseguir ter conversas recorrentes
você já conseguiu identificar qual é o
líder ou quais são as pessoas que
estiveram aqui na frente que estão
próximos a vocês
alguns quilômetros de distância que
vocês podem ter conversas contínuas e
recorrentes escolheu um de hoje têm vez
em três meses vocês terão três conversas
veja como isso vai ser modificado na sua
vida
olha que coisa bacana não adianta você
ir para o livro o livro aquele contexto
é totalmente diferente do seu
no máximo você vai se inspirar você vai
se motivar por uma grande história mas
quem vai transformar você é aquela
pessoa que está ao seu lado que já
pratica um conjunto de erros e foi um
grande observador você tem a
oportunidade de recorrentemente
conversar com ele
isso é uma mudança radical na vida de
grandes pessoas que estão buscando
líderes e que se debruçam em torno de 10
grandes livros de administração e de
liderança de biografias até de empresas
nessa grande busca de encontrar um líder
para ele e tem grandes líderes
de menor porte de grandes mudanças
imagina o xuxa conversar com um chuço
inclusão social através do esporte na
virilha é lindo mas não pensa sobre arte
contemporânea com livre
veja que coisa maravilhosa quem tiver
estudando algo parecido ou quiser
explorar uma ação sobre isso foi só com
livre que está ao lado que passou o dia
conosco e isso é que é bacana não é o
líder que está escrito no livro que você
se inspirou com a 10 citações por página
mas é a pessoa que viveu seu lado disso
a desconstrução muito importantes para
que nós deixemos de lado algumas
daquelas nossas amarras que chamo de
parte cognitiva da nossa cultura para
que nós possamos dar um passo e
modificar alguma coisa vou falar três
coisas bem rápidas a primeira é parece
que quanto maior é melhor hoje 10 duas
vezes é sempre melhor quando você é
maior quando você tem grandes grupos ou
quando você tem grandes eventos
pergunta pra nossa líder iraquiano se
foi fácil montar esse evento se foi
fácil montar os últimos oito eventos às
vezes ser pequeno para que você se torne
dependente de outras pessoas é muito
melhor e uma coisa que ninguém fala
quando você é muito grande é muito
difícil ser melhor
isso é uma frase que pouca gente ouve
às vezes é muito mais fácil ser maior é
muito até buscaria aquilo mas é muito
difícil ser melhor quando se é muito
grande por isso que as pessoas se tornam
se independentes ou independentes com o
outro eu sou dependente neste momento de
um conjunto de pessoas para que eu volte
para recife amanhã às seis e meia da
manhã
eu não sou somente dependente delas
também da pena de mim faz parte de um
conjunto de uma rede de dependência
nós somos três dependentes uns dos
outros porque nós nos defendemos
eu não preciso ser
para poder ser independente eu não quero
é ser independente
nunca jamais se a gente pudesse ensinar
alguma coisa o meu filho é meu filho
veja a frase todo mundo fala seja
independente das suas ações e decisões
meu filho
outras mães enquanto os pais falam isso
diariamente enquanto a carga de emoção é
transferido pela independência deles
para independência deles não no filho
descubra quem você vai depender de quem
vai depender de você
aliás se tiver alguém totalmente
independente aqui é porque não olhou
especificamente não buscou alguém que
seja dependente de você com certeza
devem existir várias pessoas
precisamos descobrir quem são os que
dependem de nós e para quem nós vamos
depender o empreendedor na busca pela
sua independência
é o que mais vai depender de todo mundo
eu tenho essa história porque eu já
criei 15 empresas
hoje eu tenho oito empresas e dessas 15
alguns ativa oportunidade de conseguir
vendê las e comercializá las e tenho
vários dos meus funcionários que
participam de outros grandes grupos
empresariais parte deles eu ainda
dependo deles e parte de alguns deles
ainda depende de mim é uma vida que não
cessa nunca o fato aqui precisamos mudar
alguns dos nossos comportamentos para
podermos reaprender reaprender o que nós
fazemos e reaprender ao que nós já
sabemos
esse é um desafio muito grande
o desafio de que nem tudo é não e nem
tudo é assim mas com certeza nem tudo é
relativo
existem coisas certas existem coisas
erradas mas isso depende do contexto
quanto à relatividade quanto à filosofia
vida de um jovem empreendedor tem 38
anos é um dos filhos ou casada pela
segunda e última vez com toda certeza
que eu tenho hoje essa minha
relatividade pessoal
isso depende do meu contexto vai ser
difícil ensinar esse meu filho mas
espero que ele aprenda e não por mim e
por ele próprio
o desafio das boas idéias boas idéias a
princípio móvel
o mundo boas idéias espalhadas movem o
mundo
mimi por 12/10 móveis redes sociais
no máximo o que move o mundo é a
capacidade de execução das boas idéias e
foi isso que nós vimos aqui não foi boa
ideia do henrique floresta com a
robótica e com a robótica livre foi a
capacidade de execução dele de conseguir
modificar um conjunto de um universo de
crianças através da robótica da mesma
maneira como é a capacidade de análise
da biomedicina colocada por uma das
nossas palestrantes
desculpe mas pra mim virou a mãe de
felipe
nosso desafio pois imagina a capacidade
obrigado
imagina a capacidade que ela teve que
estudar para chegar para nós com a visão
naquele momento eu estava escutando
aquilo foi olha mas ela está mudando o
comportamento na minha próxima meu
próprio no próximo receituário médico eu
vou perguntar para o meu médico em
carros desse remédio deu errado
segundo esse novo horário vai ser bacana
vai ser bacana precisamos ter coragem
para mudar alguns desse comportamento é
vou ter com ela no livro médicos esse
tipo de pergunta assim como talvez vocês
assim como tantos vocês vieram pra cá
tiveram a coragem de ouvir pessoas
desconhecidas e se influenciar por isso
coragem é sempre algo que inicia que faz
com que você até seja resiliente
eventualmente persistente alguma coisa
mas será a sua execução que esquecera
transformadora dentro do seu contexto o
dentro do seu universo a sua capacidade
de agir e desde de gerar resultados
positivos no longo prazo
nunca no início porque no início a
capacidade de alcance da sua mensagem
sempre será pequena
tudo que você inicia com coragem é o que
eu chamo e o que um grande sócio meio
que é um dos meus grandes líderes e
conversas em quadros todo todo santo dia
ele fala que é vamos iniciar alguma
coisa vamos então a gente escreve a
frase primeira execução depois em
perfeita depois do desconhecido iniciar
alguma coisa é a execução inter feita do
desconhecido
olha que bacana é claro que é imperfeito
uma coisa que eu não conheça por isso
que eu estou iniciando em outros eu
estou executando ela sempre será em
perfeita já que é algo desconhecido é
quase uma tautologia do ponto de vista
da lógica é muito bacana
tudo que você executa você tem sorte e
você tem um acaso
tivemos mais uma explicação bastante
brilhante rogério livre
o nosso físico que virou um artista
contemporâneo e ele colocou a frase do o
que gera um acaso quando a bolha de
sabão tem aquela sua vida efêmera
explorer já que ele não tem controle
sobre aquilo ele preferiu dar uma
conotação da amizade que ele tem com as
bolhas e olha que bacana ele não pode
prever o acaso o acaso só aparece para
quem executa ea recíproca não é
verdadeira a porque a sorte vem para
quem trabalha deus ajuda quem cedo
madruga falassem mentira pura existiram
que existe a seguir o trabalho todo dia
trabalho no longo prazo converse com
muita gente interage comum muito volume
de pessoas faça trocas compartilhe
colabora com todas e aí pode ser que o
acaso positivo a sorte apareça mas ela
não parece que você faz isso não
primeiro você tem que fazer é que no
dicionário dinheiro o só vem antes do
trabalho é no dicionário que vai fazer
pra gente dar certo olha uma coisa
importante aqui em tudo dá errado a
gente já sabe disso a gente já aprendeu
vai iniciar alguma coisa é melhor pensar
que vai dar errado vai dar errado tudo
vai dar errado não tem como não está
porque sempre você não tenha certeza
então o seguinte eu tenho um calendário
o calendário não desculpe um carimbo
uma indução eu tenho um carimbo
esse carimbo eu uso ele muito aqui está
uma imagem eu uso ele mesmo na hora que
chegue alguém pra mim eu só vim cá atrás
aí corre dessa forma nem vou fazer 50
anos aqui eu vou lá almofadinha vermelha
vai dar merda
[Aplausos]
e só pra gente concluir uma coisa
importante
o errado eu troquei pela merda porque na
verdade o que acaba desistindo
eu aprendi isso quando estava
colaborando com os artistas cênicos
ele disse que a palavra merda é algo
importante para eles é um desejo de boa
sorte
merda é maravilhoso e eu achava vai dar
errado eu troquei vai dar errado pelo
vai dar merda então agora isso tem uma
pergunta toda vez que o carimbo eu digo
se vai dar merda você já sabe se der é
porque você não fez alguma coisa pra dar
certo
temos sempre que fazer alguma coisa pra
dar certo já que tudo vai dar errado
obrigado
[Aplausos]